So,
this morning, today we will begin a new
chapter in al-Wajeez
following
the
chapters of
wudu
and it is a a part of the chapters of
wudu.
And that is
the topic and the rulings regarding al
massah
[Arabic recitation]
ala ma yalbasuhu al abdu ala qadamaihi
And that is
wiping over the footwear.
Now, usually this chapter is referred to
and this ruling
is referred to amongst the fuqaha
as al massah ala al khuffain
wiping over the leather
footwear.
It's not even correct to call them socks
cuz they're not really socks. They take
the place of shoes. Al khuff, as we will
go into good detail
inshallah
is
something that is not worn with shoes.
It is worn instead of shoes.
But usually this chapter is referred to
al massah ala al khuffain
and specifically this type of footwear
because that was what was most common in
the prophet's time, sallallahu alayhi wa
sallam.
In his time
they had pretty much everything that we
have now. Not a lot has changed as far
as that is concerned. Yes, the materials
have changed.
arguably the quality has changed, but
general basics of footwear are the same.
They had sandals.
They had leather
hide,
more moccasins. If you know what
moccasins are, moccasins
are kind of leather
almost leather socks, but you know,
Native Americans are depicted as wearing
moccasins. They don't have a separate
sole on them. They do not have a sole.
The sole is part of the same material
that the rest of the
footwear is made out of.
And so, they had
sandals. They had
al-khuffayn. They had
an-ni'al, which are shoes, and those
are defined as having a a sole and a a
kind of thick sole on the bottom,
usually made out of
tanned
heavy leather,
right?
Et cetera.
And they had socks, al-jawarib. They had
socks. They even had cotton socks, socks
made out of cotton specifically.
And so, not a lot has changed in that
regard.
But, usually when we look at the
narrations regarding wiping over the
footwear and what it is they were most
usually wiping over, it's usually
al-khuffayn, cuz that is what the Arabs
most usually wore at that time.
they had all of these other types of
footwear, but what would be most
commonplace,
right, is al-khuffayn.
And so, the topic is usually referred to
as an-nasah alal-khuffayn, but it
doesn't mean that an-nasah is only on
al-khuffayn.
An-nasah can take place on anything that
is worn on the feet, as we will hear,
inshallahu ta'ala. Yubtadi'u al-mu'allif
bi dhikri
tarafin min kalam al-hafidh
[Arabic recitation]
those who are considered
when documenting consensus, scholarly
consensus.
What is consensus? Ijma. Ijma is the
third
of the four
evidences in Islam. There are four
evidences in Islam.
Number one is the Quoran, number two is
the Sunnah, number three is Ijma.
Number four is Al Qiyas.
These are the evidences in Islam.
Now,
those who are considered
for scholarly consensus,
meaning if
there is no documented difference of
opinion amongst any scholars with
respect to a particular statement or
belief or ruling, then this is
considered what? It's considered an
evidence to say this is something that
has been agreed upon.
It has been agreed upon.
[Arabic recitation]
opinion that there is no difference
amongst any of the scholars of Islam,
those who are counted when looking to
document
Al Ijma, when looking to document
consensus, scholarly consensus.
Now, what does that mean?
Our prophet Sallallahu alayhi wasallam
tells us let tajtami'u ummati ala
dalalah.
He says, "My nation, my ummah, will
never agree unanimously upon a
misguidance."
So, if the ummah agrees, the scholars
agree unanimously and none of them
opposes a particular opinion, this is
considered consensus and consensus is
one of the four evidences in Islam.
An-Nawawi, rahimahullah, he tells us
that
it is a matter of consensus
amongst the scholars of Ahlus Sunnah
that it is permissible to wipe over the
khuffain, the leather footwear, whether
a person is in travel or a person is a
resident, whether a person needs to do
so or a person chooses to do so.
Whether
a person is needing to do so because
they're traveling or because it's
difficult to make wudu and wash their
feet or if they don't need to.
Just because they choose to.
He says it's even permissible for a
woman to wipe over her
leather footwear even if she's not
leaving her home.
Or even
someone who is
unable to walk, for instance, or etc.
If they have leather footwear on, they
are permitted to wipe over their
leather footwear, their
khuffaf. The only groups which were
documented to have differed
with this consensus
are the Khawarij and the Shi'a.
The Khawarij
and the Shi'a.
And neither of these two innovative
groups are considered when documenting
consensus.
Cuz they differ on a lot of stuff,
right? They differ on things that
they differ Certain groups of the
Khawarij differ on the five daily
prayers, for instance.
S- Certain groups of the Shi'a, of the
Rafidah, differ on on whether or not
Aisha radiyallahu anha is guilty or
innocent of what she was accused of.
These people, their difference of
opinion does not count
because
they have
gone so far off the
middle balanced and beaten path that
their extremist views on things makes
their
excludes them from
having an opinion with respect to
consensus.
[Silence]
the great Imam and scholar of Al-Basra
and
one of the seven original
he says, "I have been told directly by
of the Messenger of Allah's companions,
70 of them.
70 of the Messenger of Allah's
companions have told me
that
it is
the that the Messenger of Allah
used to
consistently wipe over his footwear.
70. So, this is what is 70? 70, 80, 50,
this is what we call a tawatur.
And a tawatur is the highest level of
authenticity with respect to a narration
when we look at the sheer amount of
narrators.
From the aspect of the sheer amount of
narrators, a tawatur is the highest
order and highest level of authenticity.
We will take a stop there and we'll
continue this tomorrow inshallah. Let's
ask Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
[Arabic recitation]
who imagine now when you are now
be now imagine now mean who are now or
are now
what are now or are now
or are now mean who or
mean who are now or are now or are now
or
mean who are now or are now or